welcome to another game five minute and
see form I haven't played this for a
while okay we transpose back to a Queens
gambit and he's going for the so-called
triangle set up a la always liked Quincy
to against this one reason being that F
fibers I'm really a bad move this is
some every bad Stonewall and I hope we
see in this game why this bad be six
yeah this is some usually the way to go
after be 6 95 95 is so really am really
uncommon ok let's take I mean how to
seem to take now with the C porn okay
much faster on the C file okay just I'm
just cancel i'm in the syphilis is some
a huge asset
okay the question is now brooksy one or
taking on a six take one one thing is if
I take on a six and Quincy 6 i'm
attacking the six format he's got Quincy
aid yeah okay just look see one come on
not spend so much time I mean this is
really a terrible for black end as I've
spent ages looking for the most
beautiful kind of reputation I probably
lose this nonsense on time and basically
you can play many many moves and and I
just better forever I'm saying just that
normal good moves enough here you don't
necessarily need to spend much time and
find the best move the problem is simply
that b6 is weakening the light square so
much if the Pawn would have been back on
b7 then of course Roxy 6 is not not on
but this would be a big difference for
example instead of 97 he would have had
the possibility to play 96 with a fine
position and would be 6 it's just with
GCM I have those some those light
squares and he success of course very
weak but this position also i would be
terrible with with the porn on f7 just
because of the C file okay so if i go
here he can play although i cannot play
98 so then let's do this and I be aight
i can just take and I'm threatening you
can see it now
just invading the position the next move
from okay rook CA just the simple threat
I in fact I'm just the problem is if he
goes King edge step neck and slippery
rocks yet the queen is strapped in this
position it doesn't have a square so how
does he does he even know save the queen
Bishop yeah maybe some Bishop move
Bishop f8 or something or Rukia fade but
this later this is c 6-r I can take you
six now that's some reason not to don't
think some let's just take this and turn
he's intending to go to a format Queen B
7 just a text the the bishop and it
doesn't have really a good square ok
come on I don't want to lose control of
the sea far this is the easiest way to
to play just keep the sea farm my take
on CA take on your 7 mm it's a PEC rank
mate maybe there is some way to learn to
do play better but just just keep the
advantage he doesn't have fun anything
substantial come on this is this is just
just a good end game rebooting the night
to have form trying to win the the porn
him down he doesn't really know he can
go King be seven but just going to see
five double attacking yeah maybe there
was some more precise way but I have
really sometimes you get sick of
thinking long and trying to make the
best moves and then don't win because of
time now the problem is simply in this
position even back in this position that
black has problems making a move 94 as
answered with G for this is really
forceful and this son is just just a bad
structure if he takes now with the e
porn
if everything else fails i can take ba
den to see six with a pawn except one
Queen takes is completely completely
weird exposing the Queen the center and
you've got all kinds of weak squares and
pawns and this some yeah this leads to
the the structure of the game which is
just a nightmare rooks is six and it's
it's basically gone no way to to defend
defend anything we are Queen B seven
here maybe is stronger but ok it's it's
winning um the the point is really that
f5 is already a big mistake leading two
to trouble like cannot equalize after
this move anymore or not even getting
close to equalising ok thanks for
watching